- E-mails are arguably still
the most important medium
of professional communication
in most corporates.
But writing a strong E-mail is not easy.
It's really a craft, a skill
that needs to be trained
and developed and practiced.
So welcome to another coffee break
here on my channel "Firm Learning,"
I'm a former McKinsey consultant,
and on my channel, I want to help you
to become successful in the
first years of your career.
And today, I wanna talk about
writing effective and
well-structured E-mails.
So without further ado,
let's jump into it.
I prepared an E-mail here
as a practical example,
and now we can together improve.
Let me briefly read out the E-mail to you.
Subject : Summary of Kick-off,
Dear team, thank you
for your time last week
in the kick-off,
and looking forward to meet you again
in our first Jour Fixe next Tuesday,
Paul, can you please schedule it,
and also our monthly SteerCos?
I very much enjoyed our discussion
on what initiatives to focus on
for the "New Markets" project.
We decided to not further
pursue opportunities
in the Nordics or Eastern Europe.
We agreed to focus on Spain
for a pilot for our CAVOC product line,
(goal: 20 EUR mn revenue in 6 months).
We also need to conduct
consumer focus groups in Germany
to develop new product
variations until end of year.
In addition, we want to
reduce our engagement
in the French market.
We therefore want to close
down our sales offices,
but make sure the key
accounts can still be served
from our European account managers.
As the first step,
I suggest we structure
all these initiatives
into a project plan.
Carla, can you please set one up
for our first Jour Fixe next week?
Please, everyone,
be well prepared for
our Jour Fixe meetings.
I expect to receive regular updates
from the Sales, Marketing,
and Product team leads
in these meetings.
Let's make sure we are able
to provide meaningful updates
to our board in the monthly SteerCos.
Thanks, everyone! Best, Louise.
So while this E-mail is
not completely horrible,
there are for sure several things
that can be improved significantly.
And the first is the subject line.
So here it says "Summary of Kick-off,"
where that's not wrong, but
of course, it's quite generic.
As a professional,
you might deal with different
projects at the same time.
It's always better to be
a little bit more precise,
more specific, that you
directly have the context
of such an E-mail in the inbox.
So maybe rather write something like
"[Project:"New Markets"]
Summary Kick-off,"
just to provide this context.
Let's now talk about the first
paragraph of your E-mail.
Here, you should make sure
to always have two things included.
First, provide some context.
What is this about?
What is the context of
what you're writing in?
And then, second,
also try to summarize
what exactly you want.
So if you want to schedule
a meeting with someone,
don't just write this in the
last sentence of the E-mail,
but write this in the first paragraph.
This is also the idea of
"Top-down Communication."
If you have no idea what
top down communication is,
I made available about
that in the past as well.
I will link it somewhere above here.
And in this example,
probably what makes sense,
just to provide an outline
of what you will do here,
so you will summarize what
has happened in the kickoff,
and what the key topics are
that you will write about.
Again, this provides important context.
Another person knows what to expect
when looking at the rest of the E-mail.
So let's next talk about
this structure of an E-mail.
The core of every good
E-mail is a good structure.
Notice how here
the E-mail is structured
in different paragraphs,
but these paragraphs do not seem to follow
any logical organization principle.
The next paragraph
talks about initiatives.
First, it mentions things
that the team does not want to focus on,
the Nordics or Eastern Europe.
Then it talks about an initiative
that the team does want to focus on.
Here, Spain for a pilot.
The third paragraph, once
again, talks about initiatives,
first about what is supposed
to happen in Germany,
then what is supposed to happen in France,
and then it is mixed with
information on to-do's.
And then the last paragraph, again,
talks about your fixed meetings,
the expectations toward these meetings,
and then also some info
on the monthly SteerCos
that are apparently
supposed to take place.
So let's go over different
things that can be improved here.
And first, let's think
about the logical groups,
the logical categories that
you want to talk about.
So in this E-mail,
there are three types of
information apparently
that the person wants to communicate.
First, the Focus Initiatives
that are supposed to happen.
Second, the Meeting Schedule,
what types of meetings are
supposed to take place.
And then third, the Next Steps.
What are the to-do's that
the team members have?
And when coming up with
these logical categories,
always think of the MECE Principle,
that is, of course, also
applicable here as well,
when coming up with these groups.
And if you have no idea
what the MECE Principle is,
it's a structured principle
that is very commonly used in consulting,
in professional services.
I made a video about that in the past,
that I will link it somewhere above here.
Check it out to learn more.
Next, try to use bullet-point
format whenever possible,
avoid writing long sentences,
like you would write paragraphs in a book.
You need far more words to
say the very same things.
Take out words by using
bullet-point format.
And that, again, makes
it far easier to process
for the person reading this.
Another little technique that you can use
just to increase the clarity
and provide more structure of a E-mail,
is to go beyond just writing bullets,
but letting the bullets always
start with 1, 2, 3 words,
that serve as a little
subheader for the bullets,
because now, everyone, when
they read these bullets,
they don't even need to
read it word by word,
but just for reading one or two words,
they have an idea what this is about,
can decide for themselves
if there's some errors
that they don't even wanna read,
because it's not so relevant for them,
but others that they
wanna read more about.
Next, let's talk about
distributing to-do's,
distributing the next steps to your team,
and an error that I often see,
and I think it's often quite dangerous,
is if you want that someone in the team
does certain things, you just,
in the middle of the E-mail,
somewhere mention their name, right?
And of course, if these people,
very carefully read the whole E-mail,
they might spot their name,
and they might spot here the information,
that this is what they need to do.
But in general, I think
it's a good practice,
that whenever you want to
address someone in an E-mail,
and that person's
supposed to do something,
you bold that name, right?
So in the middle of the E-mail,
you make that name bold,
because then, of course, the
person will quite directly see
that this is where you
write about the person,
and can then also read on
the associated to-do's,
tasks, things that you
want the person to do.
Let's talk about two additional tips
that are maybe not directly
related to this example E-mail,
but the first thing that
bothers me quite a lot
is this E-mail Ping
Pong that often happens
if you wanna schedule
a meeting with someone,
because what often happens is,
that one person proposes dates,
then you need to check in your calendar,
propose other dates,
and then goes back and forth.
And so, to avoid making this
process even more complicated,
make it a good habit of yours,
that whenever you ask for a meeting,
always start with some first suggestions
that you directly share.
And of course, now there are
many more modern mechanisms
with meeting links, schedule links,
that can speed up this process even more.
And the second little suggestion
is the Push for Action in these E-mails,
because often you have the
bit unpleasant situation,
that maybe you ask a question
or waiting for feedback,
and the people aren't replying,
you don't know, do they still
have a point to share or not,
and so on.
And a little technique that
I find often quite effective,
is to always then mix your
E-mails with little deadlines.
So maybe write something in the end.
So if you have any feedback on that
or any other point you want to add,
please let us know until tomorrow 2:00 PM.
And if you don't hear anything from them
until tomorrow 2:00 PM,
then you let them know
that you assume that
this E-mail is all right.
Now, all that being said,
we all know that the number of E-mails
that is written in many
professional jobs is far too high,
the number of E-mails we receive
can really be overwhelming.
So let me share three tips,
what some things are
that you should avoid,
when not to write an E-mail.
And I think the first is,
whenever you just wanna
share one or two lines,
a casual thought,
nothing that needs to be forwarded
and needs to be acted on,
rather avoid E-mails.
And many companies have
solutions like Microsoft Teams,
Select, Google Chat, and
similar solutions in place,
rather use them,
and rather don't write an E-mail
when it's not absolutely necessary.
Second, to be careful
when you wanna use E-mails
to escalate things.
We all know this feeling,
something bothers you, a little bit angry,
so let's write an E-mail,
put lots of people on CC, and complain.
So of course, these are
often also political games,
that I don't wanna say
that this is always the wrong thing to do,
but just one tip of advice
that actually I picked up
from a high school teacher
back in the day,
is that that person told me,
when you are angry,
when you really just wanna
say something to someone,
when you want to write such a message,
sleep over it for one night,
just take a break, sleep
over it for one night.
If the next day, you still feel like that,
that this is the right
thing to do, then go for it.
But often, the next day, you
see things far different.
You feel different about it.
And then you might even regret
having written such an
E-mail the last day.
And then third tip,
I picked up from a partner
I used to work with,
that person once told me,
"Good news in writing,
bad news in-person."
So if you have a good news to share,
something great that maybe
you did or your team achieved,
write an E-mail about that, why?
Because you wanna make it permanent,
because you want to give the
recipient the opportunity,
potentially, to forward the
good news to other people,
share the good message.
And then this, of course,
will be something that will
often be positive for you.
On the other hand, avoid
putting bad news in writing.
Maybe you did a mistake, you
need to come clean on it,
for these things, don't write an E-mail.
Whenever possible, pick up the phone,
have a face-to-face conversation
with the person you wanna talk to.
And here, for the very same reasons,
you don't wanna make it
too easy for that person,
just to forward that
E-mail to other people,
making it very salient,
what you did, what went wrong,
you don't want the person hover you later
in their E-mail inbox,
search for your name,
and then just, by chance,
finding this E-mail again,
reminding them of the
things that maybe went bad,
the things that you did wrong in the past.
So of course, this might be
a little bit oversimplified
for some situations,
but in general, the rule of thumb is,
"Good news in writing,
bad news in-person."
So do you have any other tips
on how to write effective E-mails,
just leave a comment
in the comment section.
Big, big thanks to all the
members or "Firm Learning"
for making a contribution,
much appreciated.
If you took any value
out of this video at all,
please just throw the Like
button for the YouTube algorithm,
and also subscribe and turn
on the notification bell.
My name is Heinrich,
and I make all these videos
every single Saturday.
See you here again on
this channel next week.
Until then, all the best
to you, and bye-bye.